another interesting thing about that I
read online apparently now because a lot
of kids in Japan yeah have had to wear
masks for the pandemic apparently
there's like and you know they've been
forced to wear masks like a lot of kids
now that are like 10 12 13 in Japan that
are really young yeah don't feel
comfortable taking off their mask at any
point yeah right so they never take off
their mask yeah yeah
um and it's a it's an extension of also
like being shy and it makes you know
more timid but also there's a really
interesting thing that they pointed out
where being like when you're growing up
apparently something for Social
Development like your brain is it not
seeing people's faces all the time is
apparently quite detrimental to your uh
your development I believe that yeah and
so if you're just all the other kids are
all wearing masks it's like this is kind
of bizarre yeah everyone just looks like
an NPC yeah and it's also a lot of kids
have reported that they just like they
feel very uncomfortable and like shy and
just not great without wearing a mask
yeah and that's just like whoa that's I
mean as if we needed any more problems
bizarre I mean even even me like even
just like the two years we've gone
through the pandemic going abroad and
seeing people not wearing masks I'm like
oh yeah that's what a human face looks
like that's what a chin looks like
that's what mouth movement looks like
when people are talking oh I forgot like
obviously mass culture has been big but
not to this understand oh no no I don't
think kids have a really wore masks in
Japan but like at school before no they
did yeah but like not only when they
were sick though right yeah only maybe
during like influenza season right right
it wasn't an all year round thing no
it's like it's like some kids chose to
wear masks all year round just because
it makes them feel more comfortable but
it wasn't like a society it was
interesting as well in this thing there
was like there was uh anecdotal or I
don't know reports of like certain PE
teachers that had to like they were like
like shouting at kids like hey take off
your mask or during P like you're not
gonna breathe outside properly yeah yeah
yeah you're gonna like you can he it's
like 40 degrees yeah take it off and
they were like apparently they were like
just so uncomfortable with the idea they
wouldn't take it off I mean I don't
blame them because even I felt
uncomfortable taking my mask off when we
first went to England and saw everyone
not wearing a mask you know and that's
me having lived most my life you know
the moment you start running though yeah
yeah that's right at the moment I'm I'm
even getting remotely physical bro I
want to rip that oh absolutely are you
kidding me yeah there's nothing worse
than [ __ ] exhaling and having to
breathe in your own just exhale yeah but
he felt guilty for like feeling that way
right no I mean well if I wanted to take
off my Max I know like in the gym you
know if if you needed to take off your
mask right I felt even though I know
even though I knew like of course I'm
gonna need to take my mask off at the
gym no there were there were still some
gyms deep during the pandemic or even
like after not even deep dealing
pandemic that you know didn't allow you
to take off my gym still says to not
wear masks but a lot of people don't
wear the masks in the gym yeah um I I
know there's some gyms where they've
banned in Japan
really yeah
right right well I know I definitely can
see that especially recently ever since
we got back like definitely it seems to
getting started getting a little more
relaxed when it comes to Mars like I've
seen every time I've gone into a corn
mini there's at least one person okay
that's not wearing it I think we want to
preface we're not like that kind of
group of uh empty maskers
muzzle off your face son like I'm not
like that like I just you know I think
that as the pandemic is easing and as as
the temperature is like 40 [ __ ]
degrees outside yeah
take I'm like I don't want to wear this
[ __ ] thing it's and it's crazy
because the government has said like
don't wear the mask outside if you're if
you know you're feeling a little woozy
and like yeah don't worry about wearing
a mask outside but everyone is still
wearing a mask outside here yeah it's
crazy because it's because even if the
government says that people look around
and it's just like that's the thing
though right are you gonna do it it's a
problem with the collective assistant
it's a Mexican standoff right everyone
is like I think it's like it was
something uh uh there was some surveys I
read about because I was really I got
really interested in this because then I
started thinking like when is this ever
going to stop like is this ever gonna
end I don't think it is no like it's
there was it was like 40 of people want
to wear masks and want others to wear
masks and the rest were kind of
different variations between like I I'll
wear a mask but I don't care if anyone
else does and I don't want to wear a
mask and I don't want anyone else to
wear a mask it was like it was like 40
to 60 but everyone's still wearing them
even though like 40 to 60 of people
don't want to wear a mask well no no no
that's that's 40 40 to me is the
majority because that's 40 minutes
yeah 40 is the majority in just one of
those options right where everyone else
might be on the fence but if you're on
the fence and you see 40 people 40 of
people wearing masks you're gonna wear
them that's what I'm saying is that like
it and again because like you said Japan
is a collection of collective collect
collectivists collectivist Society you
know everyone follows what everyone else
is doing yeah so it's like people want
like a lot of people don't want to wear
it but then no one wants to be the first
one to take it off yeah and then when
they see someone that's not wearing it
they're like wow what a [ __ ]
delinquent yeah and it's just like oh of
course it's the foreign
when they tell me to do it because I'm
I'm not I'm not an [ __ ] because I
don't I I you know because I don't want
to be an [ __ ] to everyone I don't
want to yeah because it's like it's like
okay if I'm like on a train like public
transport full of people in Pro in close
proximity yeah I'll wear a mask right
because you know it's gonna it's gonna
make other people uncomfortable and I'm
in an air conditioned room so whatever
but like I've recently like every time
every time I get off my local train
station right because it's a smaller
train station with not that many people
on my way home which is like a five
minute walk I take my mask off yeah
there isn't people around right and if
there are people it's scarce enough
where I'm not going to be in close
proximity with anyone and yet I still
get weird looks from the one guy that
walks past me being like wow I can't
believe you're not wearing a mask I'm
like bro the closest human being other
than you is [ __ ] 200 meters away I
think he's I think he's fine but that's
why you're a herbivore man you just like
if you're an animal if you're an alpha
you wouldn't care what else to say I
don't care what other people think you
wouldn't if I cared then I would be
wearing masks all the time I've been
wearing a mouse right now there are more
people I've noticed that I'm wearing
masks but I think it's just so great
it's very very slowly it's like
everything in Japan it's moving that was
like one of the few countries that had a
mask culture before the pandemics yeah
of course yeah but it was real seasonal
like I remember not in the summer it was
like people did not wear masks in the
South no yeah like I I just remember
that it was like you would see it but it
was nowhere near like no it was now
never but like the ones wearing the
masks were the weird ones yeah but I
feel I feel like if there's one country
that can that I can see just persisting
this behavior and one country that would
be I guess comfortable with even wearing
masks deep in the summer it's it's Japan
I mean like I don't even know how people
are walking around in business suits in
this [ __ ] heat you know and like I
look at people like that I'm like how do
you survive the winter it's like how are
you not like how do you not have
frostbite during the winter yeah just
it's not I don't think any it's going to
change for a while as well just because
like all the all the [ __ ] politicians
here or they all just appeal to old
people because yeah of course because
it's the voting population yeah it's
like you can't lose your elderly voters
so you know it's never going to change
because everything in Japan is
controlled by old people yeah that's why
that's why the borders are still closed
there's nothing in this country is is
even remotely catered to anyone under
the age of 40. yeah which is so sad and
that's because they don't teach the
importance of that to young people yeah
and it's not and it's not I'm not gonna
say I'm not going to say and yeah not
enough young people young people not
enough young people let alone not enough
young people caring and so what do you
have left you have an older generation
that does all the voting and they make
all the rules even though they're
clearly not thinking about the future
beyond their life expectancy so it just
stays all in the past and then young
people complain being like well this is
kind of what we grow up with so I guess
we'll just keep going yeah yeah and then
it just never changes yeah and people
used to sometimes you trees you can't be
like oh and I used to care about this
because I was down and stupid and now I
don't
um you know people used to be like oh
you're you're a foreigner in the country
you can't you can't say anything I'm
like [ __ ] I can't vote and I pay
so much goddamn tax money this country I
think I have an opinion on it I think
imagine
having an opinion like I'm like I don't
I don't if someone's like you're a
foreigner you don't get a sound like I
actually don't care I'm like [ __ ] you I
pay so much I've got them tax money
so the least the least I can do is I'm
gonna complain like a [ __ ] that
is that's the British
if I can't vote I'll complain yeah why
not I mean I don't see why not like I I
think that like this is so much [ __ ]
up [ __ ] yeah and like everyone just
wants to be like no don't say anything
bad and it's like well nothing but
nothing's gonna change unless you make
people care obviously no one who's
watching this video is probably gonna be
able to vote in Japan but I just want to
be able to let you know some of the
complaints that shout out to the 160
year old Japanese woman who live in
Japan and have citizenship and can vote
that's right
yeah there's nothing more Alpha than
changing the Japanese government yeah I
mean I mean it was funny when you said
uh initially how it started was like oh
yeah we're not having any weddings
recently in Japan and I'm just like wait
I thought I thought this was the year
where it was all weddings because every
wedding has been pushed back to this
year I mean I know several people who
have gone to like who are going and are
going to like several different weddings
and people were just like can people
stop Japanese ones right
your honor I'm going well he's Joe's
going to watch yeah Joe's going to be
the only one I'm going to the only one
this year in Japan this is the one of
three Japanese weddings this year
he's going to the point where I've like
had people be like can people just stop
getting [ __ ] married because I've
spent so much money going to weddings I
am people by the way yeah
I'm one of those meanwhile in Japan the
wedding office is like John Travolta
where is it where is it where is
everyone
yeah yeah because uh it's it is
definitely the tip of a an iceberg that
I think is just yeah getting bigger and
bigger and bigger it's just you know
until until Japan stops catering to just
old people yeah this stuff isn't going
to change because even like the the the
tax benefits they give for kids are
decent like they're good but I don't
think they're enough I don't think what
they're doing is just not enough to like
incentivize people damn how are we going
to change that oh I know maybe letting
immigrants out because that's like the
instrument who can vote like like if you
just uh oh that would be that far too
come on
I don't know how many rights
you know like they're it's like it's
fair it's it's like a uh if you want an
instant fix that will that will
definitely fix a population you can just
let him or anything but a lot of people
don't and they want to find other
Solutions and you know that's every
country has the right to do that but you
know Japan has had this problem now for
for like you know a very very very like
multiple decades and it has to come to a
point where Japan's gonna be like um
yeah we're we're [ __ ] now I mean you see
it now like you see it really coming
into causing problems with Japan the
economy is is I mean we've seen the
recently in the past few months the Yen
just kind of like bro the Yen just got
good just like yeah it's running down
mid lane
I just went on a cliff and just
committed a jump King you know it's just
like [ __ ] all the way down there man
I I did a video on the second Channel
but like the the whole fact that like
Kyoto is going bankrupt yeah it's just
like insane to me I don't think it's
actually going bankrupt I think that was
a like I think it is just I I remember
this video that was like kiddo it's not
going bankrupt that's a lie right and
they talked about it and it was
something like so I read like multiple
articles saying no it's definitely going
bankrupt
it's I think there's a few citizens
around that have actually gone bankrupt
but I think Kyoto is not at like a risk
I think it was just it's in the red I
think I remember what it was I remember
it wasn't actually going bankrupt but it
was like it was like doing some things
that were you know but one thing that I
in that video that I did find which I
was just not surprised about which might
have been a big you know factor into
that you know whether Tokyo is actually
going bankrupt or not was like I think
it was like because like you know
technically speaking Japan is letting
foreigners in right now yeah technically
technically speaking technically they
have eased their borders yeah right but
like I think there was a report that
said like between June and July 8 000
foreigners have come to Japan yeah it
also it decreased in two months there
was also one month where it decreased
even after they loosened the regulations
yeah people people just don't want to
come here right now because the the
rules and regulations even though Japan
said oh wow foreign
[Music]
a lot in the past few months and we're
just like wow how why is Japan still in
the state when the rest of the world
still has you know
have figured out their own solution to
it yeah I don't know this is good or bad
but the one thing I realized where I'm
like oh okay in Japan on the thing every
day they still say the daily covert
cases every day yeah on the on the like
the main TV show yeah they still report
them every single day and I was like oh
okay yeah because like I realized every
other country went to none no one cares
yeah no one talked about it yeah is that
good or bad I don't know but it's just a
noteworthy difference yeah
I'm just trying to give you an idea of
whether Japanese like overall mindset is
at where they still care about the daily
cases that is true yeah like I feel now
in this at this point it's just
fear-mongering did you ever hear anyone
talk about the daily cases in the UK us
or Australia no no no I didn't right no
I just and I I just well in Japan that's
a conversation stuff
cases though it's it's the gas prices of
uh
how to get every Japanese person on your
side yeah the covet cases obviously am I
right yeah am I right holy [ __ ] it's
actually the highest it's ever been it's
the highest it's ever been yeah it's
like 200 000 a day
but the Japanese would be very quick to
being late it's because we let the
foreigners in it's like no that that
okay that's so [ __ ] annoying it is
annoying it is incredibly annoying
because it's just not it maybe there
might be a factor into that but it's not
only the foreigners you cannot get 200
000 cover cases from just foreigners
they're just it's not like the math
doesn't add up no yeah and like the
thing that is very frustrating is that
they'll say these daily covered cases
and then maybe right after it they'll be
like so we've started learning more
foreigners and it's like they won't say
it but they're like it's like some
places are like implying it yeah
the the thing about like for example the
other the trains run like normal Alloys
in fact it was like that they didn't
mention that at least yeah right yeah
yeah
but what can we do away